the other big story of the week
obviously was this shooting in Tennessee
and it turns out that this was a
apparently it was a biological female
who was at least going by male pronouns
it's unclear to me if she was actually
transmitting had surgery but it sounds
like there's probably some level of
hormones or testosterone we're going to
find out all about that but I want to
again focus on the the media version of
this here is MSNBC Joy Reed and as far
as I know Joy Reid did not bring on any
of the victims or victims families or
perhaps a pastor from the church or
anything like that here she is with
trans Advocate Charlotte Clymer who I
think she is he she whatever is trans
Oaks oh just watch I think children are
only unsafe at drag shows when a shooter
shows up to kill them that's right
that's where the threat is I would
challenge anyone just to get to know
trans people we are a vibrant diverse
Community as diverse as anyone else John
from the great state of Texas I served
in the military I go church every Sunday
my faith is very important to me but God
Made Me In Her Image God made me
transgender
and to see these people so cynically
weaponize this and exploit these
children's debts and their teachers
debts
it breaks my heart I wonder what those
families are thinking right now what do
you what do you feel when you have
somebody like Michael knows at CPAC we
need to eradicate transgenderism and
when somebody like Tucker Carlson says
that transgender people are at war with
Christians I can't see Christ in their
words that's for damn sure I can't see
where the biblical principles of loving
your neighbor
and walk in the walk with Christ that
they can see I can't see what they're
seeing right now because that's son of
Christ it's not
okay well first off Charlotte Clymer on
Twitter runs around calling everybody
racist and bigoted and certainly is not
using Christ in his or her words uh but
the fact that
that that's what they're talking about
as opposed to the obvious to me if you
go into a school and you shoot children
you obviously are mentally ill let's
remove the trans part there's obviously
a mental health issue here uh for all of
these people that do this uh Ashley this
is just standard media 101 because this
case a trans person person shooting
Christians doesn't fit the narrative had
it been the other way they could have
dealt with this in a whole much bigger
way and it would be it would be way
bigger right if a Christian went in and
shot some trans people now we have a
story that fits the narrative we can run
with that
yeah and we also have this like a very
confused narrative about the about the
gender because it's usually put on boys
and men as being violent and here it's
like really which one do you go with and
it created it just completely distorts
that narrative that has been run by the
media
um so yeah I think that this has been a
a real muddled case for them and the
fact that they are a once again imposing
a narrative here where sure you might
want to have a conversation here and
there about guns and here and there
about the what's going on with
transgender people but mental health is
the thing that is not being addressed
you cannot talk about people walking
into a any place a school a church
anywhere and killing many people without
any any motive any cause any any reason
that you can point to without this being
a conversation about whatever is going
on whether that's psychosis whether that
is who who knows we don't we don't know
because we don't even talk about it this
is where it is and instead the media has
used this once again as a wedge it's a
wedge issue to push people apart from
each other to make it US versus them
instead of to think about problem and
solution if you'd like more sane takes
on our insane World check out our direct
message clips playlist and if you want
to watch more full episodes of our live
roundtables watch our round tables
playlist they're both right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell